department worked for Yahoo research for
a while prior to moving at Stanford
where he is now at the Department of
Mathematics and I believe his talk is
right here in put on top right and he's
going to be discussing include sparsit
time algorithms for embeddings and
regression problems all right well thank
you Petros and what I'd like to tell you
about today of certain questions about
embedding and these are at the heart of
a lot of the sort of low rank and
compressed representations that people
do a lot and in particular for
regression problem so this is part of
the semester theory of big days it would
be a fair amount of theory but also it's
hard to make claims about the theory of
big data if you've never seen the
practice of big data so I'll talk a
little bit about at the end about some
of the applications of these and in
particular implementations of some of
these ideas and where the theory is a
fairly clean map to practice and where
it breaks down a little bit and some
interesting questions there so when you
talk about succinct data representations
everyone has their favorite some people
like PCA and SVD and if you're modeling
the data as a matrix that's maybe the
most natural way to think about a
succinct representation you might be
thinking so the data has some sort of
sparsity structure it's either sparse or
you might want to spar safai it hashing
and sketching or related to that
streaming and sub linear algorithms
property testing the data might be a
little bit more complex than just sort
of a low rank representations you get
from PCA or SVD it might be low rank
plus noise you might want to be doing
features of variable selections that
gets to the N and P question that Mike
Jordan was just asking about does your
method work just for reducing the
dimensionality I just reducing the
number of data points or a bit of both
or can it be agnostic and handle both
and a lot of these things will boil down
to some sort of random sampling either
uniformly or not or some sort of random
projection and there's a range of forms
that can take and so we'll be talking
about that and that can appear sort of
algorithmically inside the algorithm but
it can also appear
if you just generate gobs and gobs of
data and you just have to throw out
ninety-nine point nine percent of it and
so basically throw that out according to
us hopefully a useful but fairly ad hoc
rule so this is the sort of ideas for
the week on to sync data representations
and i'll be talking about random
sampling and random projection
algorithms in particular and so i'd like
to sort of give me a quick history of
random projection some of this is
probably familiar to many of you and
some of these might not be but all of
these are random projections of one form
or another but they have some important
differences and they'll show some
developments that are going to be
particularly important so Johnson and
lindenstraße is a name that if you know
I was going to say one name but if you
know two names associated random
projection that's probably those two
back in 83 or 82 they showed that if you
take sort of a random low dimensional
space basically in a certain sense and
you take Euclidean points points in RN
high dimensional points and project them
down then you preserve distances if you
said all the parameters properly so
that's sort of a remarkable thing right
on the on the one hand right because you
know you're saying you can take points
in arbitrarily high dimensions you
project them down the dimensionality
after project them to depends on the
number of points you have but not on the
original dimensionality so that either
is remarkable and it says while you
preserve a lot in terms of distances or
it says that those distances in the
original space weren't particularly
meaningful and maybe aren't something
you shouldn't be over optimizing too
because if you can reduce the
dimensionality drastically so they were
thinking about this in the context of
another problem not algorithmically
there's been a lot of work since then
one sort of algorithmic aspects of this
so you can choose random set of
orthogonal vectors and the idea is going
to be the same if you if you simply from
the harm measure sampling from a set of
vectors that spread out in some sense
then good things happen in terms of
distance preservation but you don't
actually have to be orthogonal exactly
you can choose random gaussians and the
point there is that if you set the
parameters right then you're
approximately in at length and
approximately orthogonal in the
embedding matrix they don't have to be
gala students they can be plus minus one
variable so any of a range of things
that are have sub Gaussian properties
will do the trick and so I'll give a
particular example of this but but the
point is that it's a fairly robust
notion now it's sort of remarkable in a
sense but on the other hand
it it's not sort of trivially remarkable
in the sense that it works for l2
distances but it does not work for l1
that was shown chara car and so I showed
that and the form of most of these
results before that is that it takes
something like the time to multiply two
matrices and you shouldn't be thinking
straße and sort of thing think three
loops if you have you know a bunch of
data points it's going to take something
depending on the high dimension and
maybe something quadratic on the linear
in the high dimension something
quadratic ins in the low dimension all
right so we'll put the particular
parameters up in a little bit but for
that reason it's not immediately
applicable to things like least squares
regression just bread and butter things
that a lot of people might want to do
because that by itself is already going
to be linear in the high dimension and
quadratic on the low so just
implementing the matrix projection just
implementing that function is going to
be roughly the time it takes to solve
the original problem sometimes even a
little bit worse so it's a big deal
actually when I Leon and shaselle
developed with they called the fast
Johnson lindenstraße and this says
basically I'm going to use a randomized
version of a hadamard or a Fourier
matrix so a hadamard matrix is a 1 1 1
negative 1 recursively defined and you
can implement that with fast Fourier
techniques so they could go from linear
in the high dimension and quadratic and
the low to linear in the high comes
linear in the low plus a log factor and
that's a theoretical result but the
empirical results if you use lean
Wallace's or something very related
performs very very well solar and
woodruff had a nice result about a
couple years ago that showed that
although you don't get the same results
in l1 you can get to the weaker result
in l1 roughly by substituting the
gaussian variables by cosi variables and
a bunch of people including me and
andreas and woodruff and so on took
basically that result and made it quote
fast so what the johnson lindenstraße is
the fast johnson lyndon stressed that
result is you know the slow coaches to
the fast coaches you just make it fast
it's technically very very involved but
you know the idea is that is
straightforward so the question is are
you maxing things out and going to be
going for very technical things that
that are overly complicated or is a nice
new idea and Clarkson would actually had
a great idea about a year ago
that I want to put in the context of
randomized numerical linear algebra and
some time on but they showed that the
projection matrix can be extremely
extremely sparse and when you first hear
this it's sort of surprisingly sparse so
in the context of randomized numerical
linear algebra randomized algorithms for
matrices and data I think the sort of
big for advances were given here there
was sort of course sampling according to
row lengths if you're familiar with the
area but think of it as course sampling
we've got very strong but but very sort
of rigorous but weak bounds additive
error bounds if you're familiar with
that so you can sample according to the
lengths of columns you can do random
projections and inside the analysis
applied Johnson lindenstraße to those
columns fast or slow whatever sort of a
big advance was when geneious and I and
some range of other work showed that if
instead of sampling according to the row
length you sample according to the
leverage scores or if you're doing
projections instead of applying Johnson
lindenstraße ideas to the columns of the
matrix you apply them to the leverage
score the column to the right singular
the Rose the rows or columns the right
singular vectors if you don't know if
that is we'll get back to it but do
something a little bit more
sophisticated you can get much much
better results relative error not at
revera so that was a big advance and
that the tools was starting to be useful
they weren't immediately applicable to
scientific computing applications in
numerical applications so the next big
advance was when was basically blendin
pic when Avram and Toledo showed that
you could take these ideas and map them
very cleanly to traditional namerica
linear algebra ideas in terms of
iterative algorithms the point there is
that the dependence on epsilon is not 1
over epsilon or poly went over up so
it's log 1 over epsilon so if you want
tended it's a precision you need an
extra factor of 10 not 10 to the 10 so
now you can go head-to-head with la pack
or code like that and do well slightly
better slightly worse depending on the
details that was a big advance and I
think the next what a big advance was
the same input sparsity time results the
same very very sparse projection that
Clarkson Woodruff developed where you
know you can actually start to ask these
questions and input sparsity time not an
extra quadratic factors so don't mean by
this so the basic structure of their
result is the following and when Zhang
remaing a student of mine saw this
result when David talked about it at
mmds last year he came up to me and said
how is that even possible and that's
where
there's two too sparse and we went over
that and then he said how could they
possibly need such a complicated
analysis can it be done more simply and
I said good question let's let's figure
that out so here's the result and then
I'll describe the the two types of
analyses that really aren't because
they're very complimentary so we're
given an arbitrary matrix a and by D
think of n is tall all right I'm going
to be talking about the large end case
if you like that's just an upside down p
so it's n by P so P is going to be small
a lot of the ideas here actually will
extend so for example if you think of
relative error see you are matrix
decompositions extend the compressing
rose and our columns and features and or
data points but today I'll be talking
about mostly the tall case n is large
and let's instead of taking your random
projection matrix to be a dense matrix
of gaussians or plus minus 1 variables
or had a marg any of these things let's
take it to be the following it's a
product of s times D these are diagonal
plus 1 minus 1 matrix so you need some
randomness in their DS going to be a
plus minus 1 matrix it turns out that's
enough randomness and s so d is a
diagonal plus 1 1 matrix S has each
column chosen independently and
uniformly from the standard basis so s
is rectangular this way because you're
projecting from a high to a low
dimension and each column of s has one
nonzero all right this should be
contrasted with a plus minus 1 matrix
where the entire matrix is dense with
plus minus ones there a Gaussian matrix
the entire matrix is full of gaussians
and you probably know that if you're not
dealing with worst-case vectors but if
the vectors have some nice uniformity
structure you can replace that dense
matrix with a matrix that has log and
non zeros / oh so you can get pretty
sparse actually not extremely extremely
special priests parts you're going to
place that with log n non-zeros / 0 what
they've done here is replace that log in
with a constant number of non-zeros / 0
where that constant is going to be 1 on
average so remarkably sparse and what
they're able to show is that if s is
small this is what they originally show
but it can be improved then with
constant probability if you think about
the distances in the original matrix
between the original data points and in
the sand
to sketch the version of those data
points they're the same within 1 plus
epsilon is the usual Johnson
lindenstraße type result is going to be
so important subtleties here but that's
the usual type result you preserve
things within 1 plus epsilon alright and
piña can be computed a number of
non-zeros time it's not immediately
obvious but if you can do that that's a
black box you can solve l2 regression a
number of non-zeros time that's for a
fixed epsilon all right so that's sort
of a remarkable result so here's their
analysis and their analysis takes very
important advantage of the fact that
we're dealing with l2 and that these are
not arbitrary vectors so they take
advantage of the fact that else who is a
very structured place and that there can
only be so many outlying data points so
in particular structure they take
advantage of as the following so let's
define for a tall matrix a let's say you
as an orthonormal basis for the range of
a so its cue from QR or it's you from
the SVD the L to leverage scores of a
are the square del to norms of use rose
so if a is tall you is tall the columns
of you a unit length and orthogonal the
rows are not all right the rose could
the you could be an identity with a
bunch of zeros it could be d columns
from a hadamard so the Rose could be
anything they could be very uniform very
non-uniform let's call those things
leverage scores the calming and leverage
scores because in statistics those are
the diagonal elements the hat matrix
they're called leverage scores and
informally they quantify the data point
that has this biggest strongest
influence in the least squares fit the
key idea that they had was split the
rows of a into heavy hitters and light
hitters and if you're a theoretical
computer science background you should
start to see something familiar because
we're mapping it to heavy hitting
algorithms so what the data points into
heavy hitters and light hitters high
leverage components or heavy hitters
everyone else's light hitters for high
leverage score rows which you can show
is that the projection is an isometry
the epsilon zero you don't mess anything
up with high probability for the low
leverage score rose for the light
hitters you can use a sparse Johnson
lindenstraße transform to scoop to kumar
and SAR loss which basically says that
if the data are nice in the sense that
there's knots things that stick out a
lot then the matrix can the projection
matrix can be very sparse having log n
number of non-zeros per row and so they
take advantage of that structure
on the light hitters and then they show
that the cross terms are small so the
basic idea is very very simple and
elegant the actual proof is about 15
pages and at least younger my student
who it was a background more in linear
algebra and I looked at this and it was
actually I mean I had fought a lot of
the theoretical computer science
literature but it was it was long and
hard to follow so what I want to show
you as the result of what Johnny came up
with and this is not an outline of the
proof this is the proof I mean I could
have put it on two slides if you wanted
to chase all the subscripts but this is
the proof everything and the key idea
here is don't view it as Johnson
lindenstraße that's too powerful a
hammer and that's the point made by the
clocks and woodruff result that's too
powerful a hammer you need to take
advantage of the vector space director
so they do this we did the same thing
here and we said let's view this as an
approximate matrix multiplication so the
key idea is that you're going to let you
be an orthonormal basis for the range of
a the same thing and if that's the case
remember you as tall then u transpose
you as a low-dimensional identity all
right and with sampling rose from you
and what we want to say is that the
sample dinner scare it'll the rose from
you if you dot them into the transpose
that's approximately an identity and the
most natural way to quantify that is to
say that u transpose y ou're an identity
minus the sampled version of U transpose
you but some matrix the spectral norm of
that thing is less than a half all right
the spectrum of that thing is less than
a half all the eigenvalues and that
difference matrix are are between three
halves and a half so they're all close
to one the halves arbitrary you can make
it you know point 1 point 0 1 whatever
you like and so then you're close to
Anna Terry matrix and orthogonal matrix
compute the first two moments means and
variances the expectation of I u
transpose u minus X where X is just as
big messy expression I said x is equal
to F messy expression the expectation of
I minus X is this thing which is less
than d squared plus d / s alright would
take about a couple lines to write out
all the subscripts if you want and for
any delta less than between zero and one
if you said s to be d squared over
epsilon squared you apply Markov's
inequality a very sort of basic basic
method the probability that this norm is
greater than epsilon is going to equal
delta
and so therefore the spectral norm the
thing I told you have to bound is upper
bounded by the Frobenius norm it's less
than Epsilon with probability 1 minus
Delta which implies exactly what you
wanted all right so this is interesting
because it shows you can add up to two
very different perspectives I don't
think Fox and woodruff would have come
up with the idea of splitting into heavy
hitters and lighter is based on leverage
scores have not a couple years ago we
show that that's the key idea that you
need to get relative error they mapped
it to a heavy-hitting algorithm more
common in theoretical computer science
then we're able to back out and say if
you just feed it all through matrix
multiplication you get the result
literally in one slide so what's the
important point to remember the
important point to remember in all this
that I didn't make explicit but that's
going to be important for later is that
the embedding matrix pie in fact is so
so sparse that it does not preserve the
norm of an arbitrary set of e to the D
vectors are the usual proofs for these
things say choose a single vector so
that you preserve distances and then if
you're doing Johnson lindenstraße you
consider in squared vectors and if
you're doing a subspace embedding you
put an epsilon net and choose
exponentially many vectors and you apply
a Union bound and you show that the
result holds for every vector in the
space ok it's false is this it's very
easy to show this is embedding does not
preserve the norm for an arbitrary set
of e to the D vectors but either
explicitly or implicitly both of these
proofs exploit the fact that the e to
the D vectors come from a very
structured place a D dimensional
subspace and the reason people model
data in terms of RN is because it's a
very nice place you get good algorithmic
and statistical properties so this is a
very spectral structure characterized by
the leverage scores you'll hear more
about that either later today or
tomorrow and basically there can only be
a small number of high leverage
components right if we were in a worst
metric space where every data point
could have high leverage or influence
then this would not work but for l2 only
a small number of data points can have
high leverage technically the reason for
that is that the Frobenius norm of an
orthogonal matrix depends on the low
dimension and so there can only be a
small number of data points that have
leverage that is something comparable to
the low dimension
this is for l2 and the interesting thing
is in spite of the fact that what I was
saying is the case for l2 that you in
fact do not need to split the heavy
hitters and nitrogen you can have one
page that idea is useful for l1 for LP
for range of other things so what I want
to spend those a little bit of time
talking about how to extend these ideas
to more general regression problems and
I'm going to talk about this in terms of
P although I'll talk in detail about l1
regression since that's the P that aside
from p equals 2 is the most interest
I'll have one slide on extending the
ideas to LP regression that's
theoretically and technically actually
pretty interesting but practically less
interesting then all of a bunch of
slides on how to extend the ideas to
quantile regression which given these
results is technically pretty
straightforward but it's going to be of
a lot greater interest in applications
so the idea is we want to define the
notion of a nice matrix and I August
lead to a in orthogonal matrix and the
nice matrix we want to deal with is
going to be a well conditioned matrix
we're going to parameterize it in terms
of an alpha and a beta and a p4 LP
regression so the P is the normal
talking about and elephant beta are
going to be how not nice things are so
in particular we're going to still be
considering a tall case tall matrix a p
and let QB the dual norm and i'm going
to go with this sort of slightly non
standard notation that's a matrix norm
for a pee that's your view the matrix is
a vector and take the p Nome of that
vector so in particular for P equals 2
that's a furby Gnaeus norm for being its
norm squared but you can define that for
general p and in particular p equals one
and it's just some of the absolute
values of the components then we're
going to say that a is alpha beta P
well-conditioned if the norm of a is
small alpha could be large we're going
to be interested in the number of a is
small so the norm of a in the p norm is
less than alpha and if you take a and
you multiply it by some low dimensional
vector Z you get a new vector that
doesn't stretch or shrink in particular
doesn't stretch or shrink too much all
right and if alpha and beta are small
depending on the low dimension we're
going to say it's a pee well conditioned
basis so special cases p equals 2 as an
orthogonal matrix
elf was going to be the square root of D
because the Frobenius norm of an
orthogonal matrix is the low dimension
the Frobenius norm squared is the low
dimension and beta equals one because it
just is a rotation it doesn't stretch or
shrink vectors that's for P equals 24 p
equals 1 there's something called an
Arabic basis that's slightly worse alpha
is d naught root d beta is equal to 1
that thing exists it's not known how to
compute it quickly but you can compute
approximate RF back bases in the sense
that alpha and beta are slightly worse
and so there's going to be a range of
trade off here's maybe the standard one
but i'll be talking more later about
other trade offs but you can so so in
our buck basis if you're familiar with
this is the P equals one case this is
defined for general p and although
Arabic phases exist and are proof x
we're only going to need that they exist
but in a lot of cases you want to
compute them and you can compute things
that are slightly worse sort of quickly
so how does this these sort of ideas map
onto regression because what I've shown
you is the l2 case and I showed that you
can compute this embedding matrix that
preserves distances up to epsilon with
an extremely extremely sparse projection
and applying that projection takes
number of non-zeros time i'll say
exactly what i mean by that in lower
their terms in a few slides but think of
it as number of non zeros and a
theoretical sense for now and how does
this going to interface your aggression
because I said we could solve regression
problems if we can do this and if you
can solve regression problems you can
start to solve a lot else so we want to
solve is the following so given the
basic idea is in these two lemmas so
given a well-conditioned basis i
computed it exactly approximately
somehow but say i have it given a
well-conditioned basis you can do what
I'm going to call subspace preserving
sampling all right so if i have a
well-conditioned basis what i can do is
the following I can it takes number of
non-zeros times an extra log factor time
to compute a sampling matrix actually
going to be sampling towards the high
leverage components but that doesn't
matter for just a statement when I'm
making to compute a sampling matrix such
that if you set the parameters right it
depends on the condition number in the
dimension and P and epsilon zone but if
you so the perimeters right very
reasonably with high probability you get
this so you preserve the rank you
preserve the subspace and you get
relative error in that sense
alright if I have a give input matrix
and a well-conditioned basis I preserve
that on a not just on the well
conditioned basis and basically the if
if a is a well-conditioned basis it can
be sampling uniformly basically but if a
is not well conditions what I need to do
is bias myself towards the things that
stick out the high leverage components
and I get 1 plus epsilon on the original
matrix not on the well conditioned basis
that's why this is different in the
previous slide now if i have a subspace
preserving sampling in that sense then
you can get a 1 plus epsilon solution to
a regression problem so given an LP
regression problem over constrained let
s be that thing there sample a small
number of constraints construct a sub
problem you're still over constrained
bananas wildly over constrained Let X
happy the solution to the sub problem
then X hat is a1 plus or minus epsilon
solution to the original problem all
right so identify things that stick out
the high leverage components solve the
sub problem you get 1 plus epsilon
approximation so we can construct
succinct to low distortion embeddings
the relationship between regression
problems basically is that the low
distortion subspace embeddings really
are the key building blocks for
computing moderate precision is
sometimes sufficient or high precision
solution to regression problems in
particular for P equals 2 you need an
orthogonal matrix or you need a random
projection that it's sort of is
approximately orthogonal matrix in the
sense i was describing before giving
this embedding you can get the solution
to an LP regression problem a number of
non-zeros times an extra log factor for
p equals to you don't actually need that
log factor so two points one is that if
you have a solution to help you
regression problem you can feed it to a
low rank matrix approximation so
relative error see you are if you're
only in the top part of the spectrum if
you're interested in the coupling
between the top and bottom part of the
space is a little more subtle but if
only shouldn't reproduce in the top part
of spectrum like relative error see you
are was then basically it boils down to
this so wide wide range of randomized
matrix algorithms boil down to the P
equals 2 case either explicitly or
implicitly within the analysis the
projection algorithms are oftentimes the
latter variety so how long does it take
to compute these things how long does it
take to find the low distortion of
beddings
I already gave you one example in the P
equals 2 case so in the p equals 2 case
the example I gave was this so you can
do Q rsvd you can use ellipsoid rounding
methods due to Clarkson and others for
the l1 case for LP we generalized it if
you're going to do a Johnson
lindenstraße transform just a vanilla
one with Gaussian entries of plus minus
1 entries you can actually apply it in
number of non-zeros time there's an
extra factor of d the Koshi transform of
solar in woodruff that's the weak form
of johnson lindenstraße for l1 is
actually of that flavor you can make
both of those fast and running time a
number of non-zeros is it result i
described so I like to describe today in
a little bit more detail as how to do
this for l1 you can imagine that once
you have this for l1 and l2 you can
start and cut and paste things in
various ways and we're starting to do
that but I'd like to describe it a
little bit you tell the extension de
sparsity time l1 embeddings we're gonna
be able to construct the embedding in
varsity time this will generalize to LP
it's technically involved but I'm not
going to go into a lot of detail about
that but you should also note i have a
check here and why don't have a check
here because actually that same paper we
made the point that you can extend it to
LP and get sparsity time you can also
spend it to LP and get sparsity time
times an extra d factor you might think
that's strictly worse and in a sense it
is but if you want to implement these
things in general going to be a
trade-off between the running time to
construct the embedding and the
condition number the conditioning the
quality of the embedding and in a lot of
cases that one will actually perform
better because of that trade-off and
will illustrate that empirically towards
the end so there's been a whole bunch of
recent extensions we posted this
clarkson woodruff to get valid could get
a bunch of peace they pre posted a week
later we reposted it Nelson and newgen
roasted Miller yang so there's been a
whole bunch of stuff in the last 12 or
15 months or something is probably some
things up here that I'm not including so
if you're familiar with those let me
know I'm a whole bunch of stuff in the
last year or so now what does sparsity
time actually mean what sparsity time
actually means is the following the
actual running time is number of
non-zeros plus a poly d over epsilon so
you should think of this as varsity time
when n is very large and is much larger
than D there's going to be a whole bunch
of trade-offs and so that you might go
for a slightly worse leading order time
if you want the second order time to be
a little bit better more realistic
models of data access oh
problem you know this is in the ram with
n much greater than D we have some
promising results in parallel
distributed environments not well
characterized theoretically nice open
problem to consider more realistic
models for accessing data even in RAM on
a single machine because these things
are not the random accesses and
idealization so that's an open problem
so here's the extension to l1 regression
its number of non-zeros thank you that
would make a big difference n NZ is the
number the question was is n NZ n times
non zeros or is it number of non zeros
and it's number of non-zeros an extra
factor of n they would kill you so it's
n NZ of a is the number of non-zeros na
alright so the extension to l1 so the
plus minus one in the in the l2 case
could have easily been Gaussian right it
was plus minus one because it's simpler
but it could be gaussians in that case
it might be believable and it turns out
to be the case that if you replace those
gaussians with koshi variables then the
same sort of stuff goes through so
replace plus minus 1 variables on the
diagonal koshi variables so c is a
diagonal matrix whose entries are iid co
she s as chalk columns chosen
independently and uniformly from the
standard basis so same level of sparsity
extremely sparse oh its basis vectors
and low dimensional space were scaled by
cosi variables if you do that then
there's an S which is slightly worse
such that with constant probability in
the projected space the distances are
roughly the same so roughly the same
here means up to factors that depend on
the low dimensional space if you think
of this as something that's going to
enter a conditioning and so you might
have to iterate a little bit more later
if you have slightly worse conditioning
so this is going to be a little bit
worse than what we saw before you can
play with things and make that 1 plus
epsilon if you do to stage and some
things but for right now think of this
as low distortion but slightly worse but
this can be computed a number of nonzero
times so the proof sketches is basically
the same and just in the interest of
time I think I'm going to not go into
all the details in the next I think it's
six slides but I'll point out the
high-level ideas
let the end by D matrix you be an Arabic
basis we only need its existence here so
you can let it be that you get the
tightest results you could if you want
an algorithmic version of this you could
let it be one of the approximate Arabic
basis that i mentioned use columns a
unit length in the l1 norm and you does
instructor shrink vectors too much this
generalized the orthogonal matrices and
it generalizes to general p and this is
going to be a tool within the analysis
so it exists but we don't need to use it
and the key idea is going to be it
analogously to the l2 case given a tall
matrix a we're going to say that a tall
matrix U is a well-conditioned basis for
a so sorry and and we're given a tall
matrix a and the bases you for the span
of a what we want to say is that the l1
leverage scores of AR the l1 norms of
use rose to take your tall matrix you
can sit to the l1 norms of rows so this
is a variant of the l2 case all the nice
direct you have in the l2 case does not
generalize some of it does but in
particular biasing yourself towards
these high leverage or high influence
components of what you need to get rid
of approximation so basically this which
you take advantage of is that if you
consider the set y so consider all X's
feed X's through you low-dimensional X's
if you feed X's through you you get a
bunch of high dimensional vectors y + RN
that are in a low dimensional subspace
but they're formally an RN which is a
high dimensional space and what we want
to show is that on that set y you get
the same sort of balance low distortion
up to these d factors the notation let's
say that you j is the Jethro of you and
the leverage we i'm going to call it V
so the basic idea is going to be that
you take advantage of P stable
distributions this is a generalization
of the Koshi distribution for P equals
one on the Gaussian distribution for P
equals two and we'll be able to take
advantage of this inside the analysis in
the same way as if you flip a fair coin
a whole bunch of times you get tail
inequalities or if you consider Gaussian
random variables you get talent
equalities you can get tailing a college
for these koshi random very
holes the nature of the tale
inequalities is a little bit weaker
since the co she is heavier tails and
it's a little bit Messier but you get
both cosi upper bound tail inequalities
and lower bound tail inequalities that
say when you take us some of these
variables you can control the extremes
on the tails the upper and lower bounds
and basically we want to show is that
you don't stretch or shrink things too
much there's an upper bound result and
the upper bound we want to say that if
you consider the bases we're talking
about here and feed it through the Koshi
projection matrix you can write this out
just expand all the terms you're going
to get this thing as distributed as
something like this i'm not going to go
through it all just need of time with
all the variables mean but the slides
will be up on the presentation the point
is that you can relate this term to the
l1 norm of U of the air of the of the
nice basic arabic basis and that's d
that depends on the low dimension and
then you can apply the upper tail and
equality it all goes through so what you
want to bound get is an upper bound you
say the pi ux and the one norm fly
holders inequality split that into two
pieces the X the Infinity norm of X is
going to be related to the one norm of
UX that's because we're dealing with a
nice basis that the Arabic basis
satisfies that or LP well-conditioned
basis satisfies that and this pie you
were able to relate to d log D because
of this derivation that i glossed over
so we're able to get an upper bound case
to get the lower bound we need to use
the same idea where we split into take
advantage of the fact these are not
arbitrary vectors but they're coming
from a low dimensional subspace right
and if they're coming from a low
dimensional subspace there can only be a
relatively small number of highly
influential data points and so there's a
small number we're going to split this
index set and is the set of
high-dimensional indices in two heavy
hitters with large l1 score and light
hitters with small l1 score so let's set
out to be something depending on its
Omega is a constant and D is something
having to do with a low dimension and so
we're going to split into heavy hitters
where the index the leverage score is
greater than tau and light hitters of
the leverage scores less than towel and
the point is that the cardinality of the
set of a heavy hitters is not too large
and if you consider the Infinity norm of
the vector of life hitters it's not too
large both of those should be obvious if
you follow the derivation so far and if
not
it sort of almost definitional the way
we set it up so in the lower bound case
if you consider the one norm that with
the thing we want to bound the one
number this vector Y either it's the
case that the heavy hitters are
contributing fifty percent or more of
the of the weight or the light hitters
are so you consider two cases one is
when the light hitters are in which case
you basically can SiC consider fixed
vector Y and you get a lower bound and
then you get epsilon net arguments and
you get a lower bound not just for any
fixed vector Y but for all the vectors
in the subspace the lower bound when the
heavy hitters are dominated fifty
percent or more of the masses a little
bit more complicated in the interest of
time why don't I skip over that so you
can generalize this to LP regression you
need kalyan equalities for these P
stable distributions so we had to
establish an order among peace table
variables and get upper and lower tail
inequality just think of this is sort of
a notion of stochastic dominance that
since we don't have an analytic form for
the Koshi variables for general p you
can prove input sparsity time for low
distortion embeddings for LP so the
point is these embeddings just to remind
you you know a sufficiently sparse
applying them and implementing them as
runs an input sparsely time the same is
going to hold for general p and then you
get that extra log factor if you
consider general LP regression so rather
than going into any detail about
quantile regression which is technically
the more involved with LP regression
which is technically the more involved
when I wanted to spend the last 10
minutes and so on quantile regression
which is technically less interesting
but practically more interesting and
it'll illustrate some of the trade-offs
and maybe some of the directions that
are most interesting for these sort of
sparsity time ideas because you can
imagine a lot of datasets aren't to this
rectangular they might be sparse it
might have general matrices that are
social graphs or something and you might
say I want to do something sparsity time
and the questions how do these ideas
apply there so for quantile regression
in l2 regression we're estimating the
mean basically the loss function is
think of it as x squared so the
formulation is given here and now one
regression we want to estimate a median
so it's the one Norman it's the norm not
the norm squared of the vector but the
formulation is given here quantile
regression you want to estimate quantile
towel the loss function is Rho all the
fun with that is in the next slide but
basically
this if l2 is this quadratic form l1 is
this thing with the kink the standard
thing quantile is this kink but shifted
a little bit so you can believe that
some of the ideas boil down to l1 in
fact that's the case but it wasn't
sufficiently obvious that it was
immediate to us so it took us a couple
months to figure it out but it's
quantile regression has the sort of bent
kinked version of l1 so slightly more
formally quantile reactions going to be
a method to estimate the quantiles of a
conditional distribution of response and
it involves minimizing an asymmetrically
weighted absolute residuals so rho is
the thing i had on the previous slide
and that is tau Z for z greater than 0
and looked au minus 1 times z4z less
than 0 and that gives you that form
given a matrix and B matrix perimeter
towel the quantile regression problem
can be solved as an optimization
problems not immediately obvious but it
turns out you can minimize this thing
and just for convenience you can write a
as an Augmented matrix a and negative B
and consider not a minimization of x
over all rd but x over constrained set x
and r d such that the last coordinate is
equal to 1 so we're going to be
considering that form just for
convenience so in terms of
implementations I could spend a lot of
time describing to you the l2 and l1
cases offline if anyone's interested but
in terms of the quantile regression the
state of the art was stuff a couple of
couple codes developed by Portnoy and
conquer so if you haven't seen this
paper it's an elegant paper the
laplacian gaussian hair and the
laplacian tortoise so it's an elegant
paper it's worth taking a look at if you
haven't seen the standard trouble for
quantile regression problems is an
interior point method might be
applicable for problems they consider
things a lot smaller but on today's
machines it might be 50 by a million by
50 or half a million by 50 the best
previous sampling algorithm for quantile
regression is related use as an interior
point method on a smaller problem that's
been pre process so the same the same
line of work developed that interior
point method so how does that compare
with what we're going to be doing in a
framework we've set up in terms of
randomized vector space computations so
we need to do is to do conditioning find
an l1 well conditioned basis
because of the connections between quant
and l1 we're going to do leveraging
we're going to computer estimate the l1
scores from the rows of that matrix you
and construct a sampling matrix to draw
a sample and now rather than solving and
l1 subproblem we're going to solve a
quantile subproblem so solve the
subproblem by minimizing the sketched
version of the quantile regression
there's going to be a couple trade-offs
in terms of actually how you want to
compute the conditioning basically to
get a good well one condition basis
algorithmically remember before we
didn't need that before just needed this
existence except in the l2 case which is
easy to construct now we want to
actually compute it and basically
there's two basic ideas and you can cut
and paste them in various ways but the
basic ideas are you can either do
conditioning via QR u QR decomposition
on the low distortion embedding or via
an ellipsoid rounding so given a low
distortion of betting matrix PI of the
range of a PI a Duke you are on that
thing are just vanilla QR let R be the
matrix from QR and then a times R
inverse is well conditioned so the blend
and pick paper i mentioned do
development and toledo did this in the
l2 case this holds more generally and so
if you do a cosi projection or whatever
get the low distortion embedding and
duke you are you get a well-conditioned
basis alternatively you can call a black
box i'm not going to go into details
clarkson probably wasn't the first
developed but he had it in his l1 paper
in 2005 where you take some length of
time he had ND to the fifth we've
improved it senses and d cubes to find a
matrix R such that a times R inverse as
well conditions so remember a is tall
we're going to construct a small matrix
so that if you post multiply it by a
then you get a well-conditioned basis
and you can construct that small matrix
either be a QR on the projected version
of a or be an ellipsoid rounding
procedure a lot of trade-offs in
practice and here's a sort of a summary
of the trade-offs so the slow koshi the
soul of woodruff result gets a running
time of n d squared and the kappa is the
conditioning numbers is this a which is
you know good but not great the fast co
she has a faster running time it's
conditioning is um less good but you
know still good but it's worse there's a
trade-off there between running time and
condition number quality the ellipsoid
rounding method is the ND
the fifth and that gets a certain
conditioning of D to the five half sword
either they squared you can use a fast
ellipsoid rounding which is a variant of
that which is going to give you an ND
cubed login this is in the fast koshi
paper a year or two ago and then there's
the algorithm I just described the l1
which is spc one spc one is sparse koshi
spc one is runs a number of non-zeros
time this is basically Duke you are on
that smaller problem so do the thing we
described before Duke you are on that x
our inverse so that's going to be the
fastest it's not this we're gonna be the
best if you want you can really beat on
the condition number quality and you do
that by coming up with spc to which is
basically the same thing but Dewey are
an old soda rounding now on the small
problem not on the original problem but
on the small problem or you can come up
with SP c three that you do the same
thing but you do QR on the small problem
so if you really want to optimize some
particular metric you should favor spc
one since that's the best by running
time or you should favor spc too since
that's going to be the best buy
condition number quality if you want to
implement these things i'm going to show
you the results in ram we have
extensions of these things to
distributed environments so we have
implementations of these ideas on
literally a terabyte of data for this
quantile problem well for the l1 problem
which is it if you want to do that you
don't want the method that's the best by
running time and you don't want the
method its best by conditioner more
quality you want something slightly
worse slightly suboptimal by both those
metrics and play that trade-off and
you're going to get the thing that
actually implements the best so the
randomized algorithm for the quantile
regression is hopefully it's familiar to
you by now we're going to compute an R
such that a are as well conditioned so
we're going to get a well-conditioned
basis we're going to use that to
construct a 1 plus or minus epsilon
distortion subspace embedding and input
sparsity time and then we're going to
call a sub-problem and you're going to
get 1 plus or minus epsilon and the
running time is the sparsity time times
the log factor times the sine time to
solve the sub-problem and depending on
the size of the sub problem that may or
may not dominate in a lot of cases it
doesn't but it's something as you need
to keep in mind if you're going to try
and bridge the theory practice gap and
actually implement the things so we
wanted something synthetic data let
Synthetica time in real date I'm going
to talk about is large with the lower
shall we can put it in RAM and chew on
it but we have extensions as I said of
this to order terabyte so in non shared
memory situations where it's large with
a capital L so the basic idea here is
illustrated here so you probably there's
a lot of things that you can't see in
terms of the level of resolution of the
figures the point is that the x-axis
here is the number of samples that we
draw the y-axis is quality down as good
a couple different values of tau a
couple different quality metrics etc but
the general behavior is that you get
some level of quality and if you sample
a little bit more you're going to get
better and better below some level
things fail non gracefully and things
feel non gates really because you fail
to capture the whole part of the space
and in this regime the reason you want
the better sampling or conditioning
method is because it allows you to
downsample more aggressively so you fail
gracefully the blue here at ten just
over 10 to the 2 rather than whatever
color this is which is close to closer
to 10 to the 5 so it allows you to sit
down sample much much more aggressively
by that particular metric the running
time is given the strong men are the
these two the no conditioning and
uniform the red is the best by running
time SPC one blue is spc to the best buy
condition number quality red sorry the
green is spc three which is best buy
neither but is only a little bit wet
worse by running time and a little bit
worse by condition number quality what
you see is the following as the high
dimension changes actually on the
objective and on the value of the vector
achieving that objective greens going to
be the best then blue then then read
these things are roughly flat after
initial phase which you'd expect just
from general considerations same sort of
thing here as you see as tau changes
Green is going to be the best then blue
then red because it puts the trade off
as a function of the low dimension we
can be up to something on the order of a
billion for the large to mention the low
dimension gets up to about 150 or 200 so
billion by 200 matrices we can look at
the running time Reds the best but
greens going to be only marginally worse
in particular when you gets larger
values of the low dimension what's the
real data let me not go into that just
nature's of time and let me just say
it's going to be
bunch of sort of i think obvious and
non-obvious extensions here so extend i
think the the most interesting but well
one of the ones that may not be
immediately obvious to certain people is
how do these ideas extend a low-rank
approximation because if you read the
initial papers they say all the stuff
goes through the low-rank approximation
and that's true in a weak sense of the
word so you know hoping problem extend
the inputs varsity idea is to get
improved low-rank approximation of
arbitrary end by D matrices with a low
rank parameter K so the one plus a minus
epsilon inputs varsity algorithm for l2
regression does give you one plus or
minus epsilon approximation for a week
notion of low-rank approximation namely
if you're only interested in the top
part of the spectrum the thing relative
error see you are and relative our
projection algorithms from a couple
years ago did if you want finer notions
say that you want to get finer bounds
you want exactly K columns you want to
project onto k plus 10 dimensions etc
that really requires finer control on
how the top part of the spectrum in the
bottom part of the spectrum interact in
the sketch space the column subset
selection problem if you feel like that
for that you need some control on how
the top of Bonaparte of the spectrum
behaved and it's not immediately clear
this projection does that because this
projection is so sparse that it takes
important advantage of the low ranks
structure it took important advantage of
that once you mix all that extra space
and it's not immediately clear that you
can control those various terms can you
do that if you go to slightly higher
density so Nelson and Nugent have a
bunch of results generalizing the l2
case that we had the moment method
looking at spar see trade-offs can you
exploit that and actually in most
applications scientific but also
numerical where these things have been
applied and implemented use these more
finer notion so that's why it's
important to understand these
connections in terms of extending these
and put sparsity ideas extend the inputs
varsity ideas to get better statistical
properties we're so so sparse it's not
clear that we're going to get the
general advantage of projections with
concentration might give us a
statistical side effects that you see in
a lot of these randomized HX amalgams
understand those trade-offs a little bit
better go beyond linear regression to a
range of other regression problems
coupled with stochastic gradient descent
and there's some connections so that we
understand there so so I think there's a
whole bunch of questions this these
inputs varsity regression problems
really sort of illustrate the interplay
between some of
algorithmic ideas and some of the
statistical ideas and it's actually sort
of remarkable it you can solve l1 and l2
regression and input sparsity time even
up to lower order terms and I think it
raises sort of a lot of interesting
questions for sort of sparse data and
succinct data representations going
forward so with that let me wrap up
so the question is the Koshi
distribution has a heavier tail so is it
stable you tell me open problem so so
the results I was describing we got to
work we can get all the parameters and
so on in the theory working out so to
the results go through on l1 regression
and the quantile regression problems I
was talking about you know it works
actually surprisingly well it works a
lot less well than l2 and it works a lot
less well than l24 Ranger reasons one is
that the when you project down the
distortions in general worse and and one
of the reasons is the ones not as nice a
place as l2 but technically it's because
the Koshi variables have heavy tails and
so we have weaker control on the tail
distributions I don't know how the
various statistical properties would
behave and that's that was the open
question I mentioned so the short answer
is it's stable enough to get at least
some results and you tell me here from
today whether it's stabled enough to get
what you want